you said once you said you would rather
you think it's safer to do a bare
Knuckles fight than with gloves I mean
that's be to the average person like
bass what are you talking about bare
Knuckles is safer than gloves why would
you say that CTE wise yes because bare
Knuckles the glove got invented because
to protect the hand right we all a lot
of people think the head is not because
people were breaking their hands in
boxing in the in the past world champion
broke his hands can't defend his title
now you see so then you go we got to
come up with something so then they came
up and put the glove now it became very
dangerous that's why boxing is still had
the highest rates of people dying
because the boxing glove can let you hit
as hard as you can Mike Tyson every
street fight he was in right he broke
sand
you see pretty much every street fight
he was and he broke his hand but is he
perfectly wrapped now it's a freaking
weapon so in bare knuckle boxing the
great bare knuckle boxes what they do
they ease up on the head because if you
had a skull well those little tiny bones
are going to lose